today's topic
you read the title nah now if you read
the title you already know
hey god go ahead oh my god
head on what do you want me to go ahead
no
i'll give you the floor what the hell do
you want me to go ahead on bruh
it's like yeah let's charge reparation
fees to white people
and then white people attending versus
the people that you want really to
charge are not going to be there
it's like oh wow wow where to begin with
this one where to begin they're going to
charge
up to 50 an event
as you know june is uh pride months all
right
and you can see that and all the
application and all the logos of all the
companies that you know
changing all their logos to a rainbow
flag why they're changing that because
of
money that's why uh exactly and that's
exactly the point
where we start from we start from
that they change their logos not
because they care because of
money that's it money in the bank
shorty what you drink do they change
their logo
to a black logo in february no they
don't
why money we don't hold the money
but the pride do so that's why they
changed the whole logo
okay they might do a little thing
sprinkle a little couple of things here
and there to make it look nice
but all in all money
i remember once abba said that it was
like racism was a thing
it was it was a money thing it truly is
a money thing you increase the money
change [ __ ] change faster i'm not saying
that mentalities are going to change as
well
but people are going to be able to be
more
able to accept fake take baseball
we were not allowed to play baseball
and jackie robinson came and the owner
was like wow
i'm really not digging this but i'm
really digging my money
so more money more problems but also
more money more money there you go
jackie was able to play and we're gonna
be able to do that
and you know to do a bunch of things
marketing around that
he gonna be able to you know beat all
the white dudes now the white dude's
gonna beat the want to beat the black
dudes
literally but that's gonna be that why
money he was more capitalist than he was
racist
you understand what i'm saying i'm
talking about the owners them
that's the same thing now bring it back
to here after all those companies put
the rainbow flags everywhere
you walk into a bank you walk into this
you walk into that
rainbow's everywhere this isn't
reparations
again dipping into the white guilt
it doesn't solve anything the narrative
doesn't change
a reparation fee for what you think is
gonna
get more people to your event the people
that are gonna come to the event
are really people they're gonna wanna
support and people that are already part
of this event and doing what they have
to do
the people that should have reparation
or should pay reparation
are not going to go to that event right
they're like i'm not going to go there
you're going to have less people
going to that event you're not going to
have people paying that 50
reparation because they understand the
struggle or they see
no they're going to pay that to look
good
just like those companies put that flag
to look good and and then after that
making money that's what that's what
happened that's what it is but
if it makes you feel good make it feel
good but that
oh but you're saying this is a no
for you this is a no for me just it's
just the virtue signaling
is just ugh so should
clubs be allowed to let women in for
free
it depends on what we're talking about
should women i'm not saying i'm against
the reparation they could do the
reparation fee i think it's stupid
same thing when clubs do it they could
do it if they want to
i don't think it makes sense after that
you want equal
the same girl that i want to say oh
equality inequality this are going to be
like oh let's
take profit of that so to me it's just
stupid as well
it's as stupid i'm not saying these
shooters should not do it
there are grown ass people do your thing
boo boo honey chicken cherry choco honey
bunny bunch with a slice of lime in a
cherry on top
it's all you you want to charge
reparation fee you want to make it a
hundred dollars
make it a thousand dollars i don't give
a [ __ ] i think it's stupid
you want to let the ladies go in the
club for free go ahead
oh by the way back in montreal it was a
good time
there was that club that was good it
lasted a few months alright it was
called sega freddo
they used to let the man enter for free
and the ladies pay 20 bucks hold on
hold up let me let me finish all right
they used to let the ladies pay
20 bucks and the man go in for free but
the ladies were drinking for free
it's all about the power dynamics right
a man to have some kind of game
cannot flaunt his money or his drink the
girls already have drinks
what you have to bring to the table so
the women were there
it was free for them and the guys would
come to the club
they would buy their own drink but at
the end of the day
i don't think it was really viable
because you know
you can't last that much that much time
like that but that was a good time i
gotta agree
i gotta admit that was a good time the
vibe was dope because the guy had to
work
extra cause you know montreal guys ain't
got no game i gotta say they got in the
game why
because the girls look beautiful they
don't need to have game but that was a
good time
bring it back to our basic uh
point to answer your question abba
no i don't think it it i think it's
stupid to let the ladies come for free
because we know it's stupid it's as
stupid
but you want to do it you want to charge
the guys 15 bucks and let the ladies go
for in for free
do you boo boo i think it's stupid but
sure
anyways i know the dj i'm pointing in
for free too so
yeah i mean listen if your definition of
inclusivity is being
exclusive cool
you know this looks stupid to me the
whole reparations this is not the way to
do it
okay but it's not the way to have that
conversation um
the whole thing is cringe this whole
white guilt thing that's that's really
pervasive cringe and if people want to
pay this white guilt tax go ahead
i think it looks stupid um but don't kid
yourself you're not doing
a great thing and it just speaks again
to the whole victim
olympics where it's like well gay people
are struggling
but black gay people struggle even more
and then trains
that gave whatever and then
disabled it's just like you're always
gonna find ways to exclude people and
become more tribalistic so
you know it is what it is i enjoy
watching it from afar it's funny to me
to watch this kind of nonsense
but hey why people should have a
reparation uh
fee of fifty dollars that means
especially it's a pride event
black people black ethos that sure
people should have a fee as well because
they
people that listen to hip hop should
have a fee too you know like he said
there's always going to be someone
that's suffering more here's what i'm
going to say
i want them to ban this and to make this
illegal
right because i want to go to clubs for
free i'm not even gonna lie
i want to go to club and if i'm not
gonna go close for free
i want her to pay why
because i don't like it when i'm in line
and women look too happy going to the
club
you shouldn't be that small and to pay
twenty dollars for code check
and your entry but they don't pickle
check they need the the quote of the car
and anyways coach check is uh co-check
is really something
you shouldn't be that happy it's a north
you shouldn't be not smiling
like i only smile once i'm grinding up
on somebody
that's it once i hear the music i'm like
okay
oh baby
oh oh oh gotta get to know you but you
in the line be like oh basically getting
in for free obviously not even see
come on girl that's a hustle girl's
girl that's because i know i get it i
don't know
i'm that girl i'm dead girl
now you're that girl because our name is
a little bit known we go to certain
clubs they're like yo
come right in you don't even and then
i'm like hey you don't even you don't
look right
you're not even that girl you're not
that girl cause you don't go out that
much
bro that's not you i go up once once a
week once every other week not that much
i'm that girl that's a lot once a week
is actually what
i'm that girl well you don't think once
a week is alive it's high
that's a lot inside that's when you how
did i tell you when i'm working
out if you work in barcelona i'm talking
about you you do
comedy you're sir i'm that girl i do
comedy do i go to
exactly one shows a week so for you a
week
yeah but you're not at that you you go
you do your thing you bounce i'm still
there
i'm still there you went through the
words it doesn't matter don't take that
i'm not
even trying to i took it just because
it's a shoe hey hey took it
part of the one percent you're part of
the point zero one percent i bought it
the
baby yeah i'm at the club every week
yeah at the club every week okay all
right
can't let you take that from me i can't
let you take it i give it back cause you
know i give it back them people i give
it back they're not at the club every
week no of course not okay but you know
me okay you know me but you know why i'm
at the club every week what
is it
i'm at the club club i'm at the club on
monday
and pay your reparations all the energy
squad i see you
well what's up
[Music]
fake is